zoe saldana gushes over her guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 co-star chris pratt and
he's my favorite and Kurt Russell Kurt
Russell is an exceptional man is that a
rifle you don't know what a rifle looks
like it's just swords were your thing
and guns were mine but I guess we were
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that it's pretty clear Zoe and Chris
have great chemistry on-screen but the
actress told DT on Wednesday
she's an even bigger fan of Chris as a
person it's careful and considerate of
others in order for you to be an artist
you have to have some kind of ego and
for some reason Chris Pratt knows how to
tame his ego and he allows his human
side to just still flourish and he's the
nicest actor that I've ever worked with
I never really have favorites but but
he's my favorite and we won't tell him
Zoe had even more praise for another
co-star Kurt Russell I have a great deal
of empathy and love and respect for a
man that raises other man's children and
this man has excelled at it for decades
and is his children praise him for it
every single day but you know that Kurt
Russell is an exceptional man besides
being an artist um was a treat and a
check off my like my bucket list and who
the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
[Music]
you